[Music]
[Music]
- 70 started in about 1970 at that time
our department head was in charge of the
first design course herb Richardson and
we gave the students a creativity kit
and I was a graduate student at the time
and worked closely with the students and
learned that for their first design
project it was really hard for them to
decide what to do so the next year we
decided that we'd give them a kit of
materials but give them a very specific
thing to try to accomplish and they got
into it immediately and that sort of got
the ball rolling and 270 began with a
very simple contest that involved making
a machine go down a hill in three
minutes
back then we had about 30 students in
the class and maybe another 15 or 20
people came to watch the contest and it
happened in one of our classrooms it's a
very modest beginning actually the the
genesis of the design and build part of
270 came from noticing that most kids
had never really designed and built and
seen mother nature evaluate something so
we thought that the design process would
best be illustrated by getting them in
there and doing it the thing that's kind
of different about 270 is that it was
born a little premature he started doing
it before other folks got into it but it
grew up really strong and it grew up
with a great attitude the students here
make the contest what it is and they go
at it with an enthusiasm and a
commitment and a sense of helping one
another that's wonderfully unique I
think the thing that makes the 270
experience quite unique is that for most
of the students they've never done a
really public demonstration of their
ability to conceive something and build
it and they kind of give birth to
something and they watch it as it goes
out and does its task and that's done in
a very celebratory environment the
students all know that we'll still
them if the machine doesn't work but
it's done under a great deal of pressure
so the mix of pressure and forgiveness
and the process of really doing
something it's a great mix one of the
things that's important about 270 is
that it comes at the end of a great deal
of expectation the students have seen it
on television they know about it
they think about it in advance and they
get into it and it ends up being a
really exciting thing to do for some
reasons that I don't really understand
but building something and launching it
out into the world and heading it too is
really exciting so they think about it a
lot they work on it really hard and
after it's over there's a tremendous
feeling of satisfaction and relief and
that's an important event in one's life
one of the ways to think about why 270
is important is to look at Thomas Massie
Thomas came to MIT because when he was
in the seventh grade he saw the 270
contest on television and said I want to
go win that and he came to MIT as he was
a senior in Macao in electrical
engineering
he took the course and won the contest
obviously lots of kids think about doing
that it's a big deal one of the things
that's happened is that the culture of
the course has evolved in a way that
helping one another is one of the core
ideas that came from the students and we
have allowed it to flourish and it's now
part of the core tradition they learn
from one another a lot more than they
learn from us and I really like seeing
that happen you know the thing that's
really important about the 270 deal is
that it's a shared commitment the
students here from the staff and the
faculty that we're going to work hard to
make this thing work well we're going to
put a lot of energy into defining the
contest so that it's interesting and
we're going to work hard to support you
and help you and the students respond to
that and they work hard and they put a
lot into it and that deal where everyone
is agreeing that this is something
important is the key ingredient that
makes it work
I think one of the really nice features
of the course is that it gives the
students an opportunity to remodel
themselves they discover that they can
in fact take a chaotic kit of materials
and use their creativity and make
something wonderful happen and if you
trust your own creativity you're very
likely to have a more satisfying life
than otherwise I think probably the
single most important ingredient of a
good contest is to make sure that it has
been ambivalence scaled right so that
even the staff are the people that
concede the contest have no idea what's
the best solution so if you balance
things properly
then among the people that are talking
about there's a heavy argument about
which way to go
that drives diverse solutions in fact
one of the contests that I designed some
years ago called the potentially Great
Race was terrible
because all the solutions looked alike
it was optimizable it was predictable
and I just didn't see that in advance
one of my favorite 270 stories centers
around a slide that I have of a student
looking at her machine as it goes over
the top of a sand covered hill and it's
important because she had come to my
office crying I hate this course this is
terrible I've never built anything I'm
not going to make a good grade etc and
she hung in there did it her machine did
what she wanted it to do and she ended
up becoming a designer I like that story
the 270 contest evolved to where it is
today when we first started it was a
simple machine doing a single thing
while people watched and it was quite
slow after a while we had machines
side-by-side doing things so you could
see some competition and then we got
interested in what happens if the
machines actually collide in the middle
and compete for territory and from that
we evolved robotically controlled things
so that they were not automatic that
students were controlling them while
they were doing things and that has
become a much more interactive
interesting thing to watch actually I
have two favorites one was called the
harvest which involved a wavy table and
300 ping-pong ball
and it was really wonderfully dramatic
contest because of the diverse ways the
students approached it the other was
called the summit meeting which was a a
mountain and involved raising a
ping-pong ball high over the summit of
the mountain and the students built
wonderful tall towers and diverse
machines and they both just worked well
we all want to be happy wise people have
pointed out that you can't make people
happy by taking away the things that
make them unhappy in this course many
students learn that they can become
happy through the satisfaction of being
creative and that's really a wonderful
lesson
mother nature applies all of her rules
all the time